[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster today a
mix-and-match
vaccine trial and a pause on the rollout
of the johnson johnson vaccine in the
united states following
blood clot concerns in a moment we'll
discuss all of that with the chairman of
the u.s firm geo-vax which is trying to
make its own covid vaccine
plus as the cameron criticism rumbles on
we'll talk to labour's rachel reeves
about what they want to happen now
also this morning hoping to get back to
the skies
aviation leaders will meet mps today to
discuss
plans to reopen international travel
i'll be joined by two of those giving
evidence
the general secretary of the british
pilots association
and apta which represents travel agents
that's at half past seven this
morning and we hear a lot about blood
diamonds
this is blood shrimp making waves at
half nine we're joined by the
environmentalist george monbio
and terry portman from the call for fish
campaign
to talk about the documentary see spirit
scene that
claims to shine a light on commercial
fishing
it is wednesday the 14th of april
pick and mix a new development for
scientists trying different jabs for
different doses that could speed up the
vaccination program
back to work the queen returns to royal
duties four days after the death of
prince
cease your philip behavior and disperse
peaceably you'll be arrested
the third night of protests in minnesota
as the defense begins in the trial of
the former minneapolis police officer
accused of killing george floyd mps to
vote on whether to set up an inquiry
into david cameron's lobbying activities
for the collapse financial firm
greenfield capital we track down the
italian whistleblower who's accused the
world health organization
of shelving his report which could have
helped other countries prepare for the
pandemic
and into the forest we investigate why
the uk's trees
are at crisis point
high pressure keeps the weather calm and
settled over the next few days so it's
lovely for getting out and about
but still overnight frosts to watch out
for all the weather details coming up
shortly
well very good morning to you scientists
hope it could
offset supply chain limitations and help
to speed up the vaccination program
a study looking at the possibility of
alternating between the oxford
astrozenica
and fisa covid19 vaccines for different
doses
is being expanded to include two
additional jabs the moderna
and novavax vaccines iva bennett reports
now
on the hopes for mixing and matching
doses
individually they're already seen as our
best defense against coronavirus
but can combining vaccines make those
defenses even stronger
the mix and match approach is seen as a
potential solution to supply issues
not just here but around the world
vaccine supply may not be as
regular you may get a big delivery of
one vaccine and then
a few months later big delivery of
another vaccine you're not going to be
able to control the
supply in the first and second doses as
well perhaps as some other countries
so these mixed schedules might well be
the key to getting two doses
into as many people in the world as
possible the original comm kov study
looked at whether two vaccines could be
mixed oxford astrazeneca
and pfizer now it's being expanded to
include the moderna and novovax jabs too
volunteers will be randomly allocated a
second dose regardless of their first
the research is being led by the
university of oxford sky news spoke to
some of those taking part
when it began in february just really
keen to try and get back to normal
so we do anything to help you know then
um
i'll do it because i'd really like to go
on holiday to be honest anything like
this that's going to help and save lives
and speed up the way that they can
vaccinate people as well is all you know
an advantage the novovax jab is still
under review by britain's regulator but
yesterday saw the first modernity doses
given in england
after its rollout in wales last week and
these people in reading were among the
first to receive it
at the moment second doses must be the
same as the first not everyone here
was keen to deviate from that i think
i'd rather have the same dose
of the same vaccination yeah i'd take
anything
i think as long as long as it's trusted
that's fine no i think i'd prefer them
both to be the same to be honest i don't
know why
but i don't know i just think you feel
more far more comfortable if it was the
same
any promising results will be assessed
by the regulator while researchers hope
to uncover
the golden ticket a combination that
gives an immune response
even stronger than the individual
vaccines
either bennett sky news
well meanwhile the rollout of the
johnson johnson vaccine has been delayed
in the united states and europe
following concerns over rare blood clots
the us uk and eu have ordered hundreds
of millions of doses of the johnson
johnson of the nearly seven million jabs
given in the state
six blood clots have been reported and
there's been one death
a similar rare clotting disorder concern
has been raised for the astrazeneca
vaccine in europe
and its use has been suspended for some
age groups in several countries
both vaccines work in a similar way by
using another virus to carry genetic
material from the coronavirus protein
into the body well let's talk to david
dodd who's the chairman and chief
executive of geovax which is currently
working on creating its own
covid vaccine it's good to see you this
morning can i ask first about the
johnson and johnson
concerns i mean when we look at at
just how rare these these i mean in some
cases tragic side effects are
how concerned should we actually be
well we should be concerned but we
should put in perspective just as you
note we've had almost 7 million doses of
the johnson johnson vaccine administered
there have been six reported blood clots
and one unfortunate death that needs to
be investigated
the technology of using the johnson
johnson as well as the astrazeneca
is based upon a type of virus which is
uh
is known to have some relationship to
blood clotting protein so
we don't know if these six women were
taking other medications that may have
enhanced that clotting nature
or what it needs to be thoroughly
investigated it should be a concern
but we need to also away the benefits
versus the risk
so there are other options out there
which we're very fortunate to have but
still we should investigate this there
should be there could be certain
sub-populations you know women of a
certain age group on other medications
that could be at higher risk we need to
understand that
yeah i was going to talk about those
subgroups because
clearly this raises concern for
everybody
you know the general population will
look at this and and it does raise some
red flags like it has done with the
concern
over astrazeneca and yet i know you've
you've been quite a proponent of talking
about how different vaccines
affect different subgroups in very
different ways
that's true and that's a very important
point to make we need to recognize that
first of all the mrna
technologies the moderna the pfizer
biointex
that's a new technology it's able to
move forward very quickly get products
produced and made but it's a new
technology
we really don't know what long-term
effects may be so we do need to study
these things
the adenovirus has a relationship that's
been linked
historically to blood clotting proteins
we don't know how prevalent that is
and then there are other technologies
such as what we use at geovax which has
been a
round for many years and is known for
his exquisite safety and is used
specifically for populations who who
have comorbidities and other at-risk
factors so
i think eventually and what many people
in the industry are looking forward to
are a variety of vaccines based for
certain types of
groups and cohorts i mean the the i i
think i'm right in saying am i that
you're looking the g of x is is looking
to be a
a single shot vaccine i mean moving
moving forward
that is obviously going to be of great
benefit if we can
get to that point with a safe vaccine
that that's correct uh the the the
technologies the adenovirus the j and j
astrazeneca
and even the moderna the bioin-tech
pfizer
they allow you to address one virus
protein at a time which means if
the variants do in fact continue to
emerge the uk variant the south african
et cetera
we'll probably have to see
reconfigurations on an annual basis
depending on the variance
our technology is one that enables us to
encode multiple virus proteins
it's slower to be able to get to
manufacturing but it does give you a
broader
coverage and the opportunity for single
dose with minimal refrigeration
so we don't think ours is a replacement
for the others we think it's an addition
too and when are you likely to to come
to market with that
ours is is much slower we have yet to be
uh widely funded or heavily funded by
the federal government in january of
this year we announced
our first funding from the us nih we
expect to receive
additional funding and we're right now
engaged in testing that includes uh
animal testing against the south african
variant so we'll be able to get a
picture over the next month or so in
terms of how well we protect against
that
in animal models and hopefully with that
we'll be able to accelerate and go
forward and
and in less than a year be into the
clinic
in the meantime though as as you say
you're you're
looking to be an additional rather than
a replacement for what's on the market
what do you make of the the ongoing
research now into
the the the mix and match approach with
different vaccines
for different doses i mean it is is are
there possibilities there because that
could be a
a huge step forward when it comes to the
problems with supply chains
it's an interesting concept but we need
to keep in mind that
they were talking about mixing and
matching of technologies that have not
been utilized in human vaccines before
and we really
that the issue is we just don't know and
we need to understand that does not mean
that we shouldn't study it and we
shouldn't evaluate it could certainly
improve the availability of distribution
on a global basis and that that's
absolutely critical
but we do need to understand uh the the
what happens when you start mixing and
matching
going across different technologies and
what is not not only the immediate
risk and benefit but also longer term
i mean you you talk about i think you
said mrna for the astrazeneca and
and johnson and johnson's is the fisa
vaccine working in a different but on a
different basis
yes the mrna is actually the moderna in
the the pfizer bio intact
technology and it does work on a
different basis than what one sees with
the johnson johnson
and astrazeneca they work on a
particular virus called
adenovirus uh that which has been
historically linked uh certain
antiviruses have been
to blood clotting factors that's not the
case with the technology
that is utilized by moderna or the
pfizer bio intake type of
technology but we but those are also new
and we need to understand those and
that's really what the challenge is
and why we do such extensive trials on a
typical basis
so it's interesting that you did a lot
of your concerns about the mix and match
should be
you know the potential long-term effects
of this which obviously is
is problematic when we're trying to get
things done pretty quickly
that's correct for instance if you look
at a at a pop a cohort population women
of reproductive age that actually fits
in with the
18 to 48 ages that we're seeing with
these women the six who
who've reported blood clots and and what
if they're taking
oral contraceptives which we know have a
history of blood clotting issues no
and if they're also on an adenovirus is
that putting them at an
unacceptable risk it may not be but it
needs to be monitored it needs to be
understood so we need to understand
these we need to understand more
about for certain cohort populations and
co-morbidities
what is the appropriate uh vaccine
pathway to consider for people in such
situations look it's really good to talk
to you this morning david thank you and
thanks for staying up to the middle of
the night for us
thank you okay let's have a look at the
latest coronavirus figures then
and in the most recent 24-hour period
2472 new cases of kovid 19 were reported
with 23 more deaths that brings a total
number of people who died within 28 days
of a positive test
to 127 123.
another 59 905 have had their first
vaccine
and 201 191
have had their second dose that means a
total of 40.1 million jabs
have been given across the uk
now last night more people flocked to
pubs and restaurants to celebrate their
newfound freedom this was the scene
in soho in central london pretty busy
where groups of people
convened in spite of the cold to take
advantage of pub gardens and alfresco
dining
police patrolled the area to make sure
that people kept
to the social distancing rules
now the queen has returned to royal
duties just
four days after the death of the duke of
edinburgh
let's talk to our correspondent ashna
huranak who's in the newsroom for us
this morning it seems i have to say like
a pretty quick turnaround
it really does steven this was the first
in-person event that the queen had
attended since the passing of the duke
of edinburgh on friday
and it was to mark the retirement of the
household's most senior
official lord chamberlain former lord
chamberlain earl peale
and he has been that former kind of
senior aide for about 14 years he has
been the person that
the queen has turned to for every
instance every first instance that main
connection between the sovereign and the
house of lords
and ultimately until very recently the
main person responsible for overseeing
the funeral arrangements for the duke of
edinburgh
himself we found out on the weekend when
uh the duke
passed that the royal family would end
two weeks of national mourning but then
he would continue
to undertake engagements at appropriate
circumstances and this
was deemed to be an exceptional case the
queen attending though really does
typify her deep
sense of duty and that um extraordinary
lifelong commitment that she made to the
country absolutely within four days of
her husband passing of more than seven
decades her
appearing for such in such a way is is a
huge
mark of the character she is we know
that the royal family have been
gathering around the monarch in the
run-up to saturday
which we know is the day for the duke of
edinburgh's funeral which has already
been billed
as a funeral like no other with an
extraordinary amount of armed forces
personnel due to attend
okay ashna thank you well just to remind
you that we will have full coverage of
prince philip's funeral
here on sky news our coverage starts on
saturday
at half past 12.
we're still to come this morning today
marks a hundred days until the tokyo
olympics so at a quarter to eight
we'll talk to gold medalist heptathlete
denise lewis
to look ahead to how coronavirus
restrictions will affect the games
at half past eight we're going to be
talking about sudden adult
death syndrome with a mother who lost
her son and is now
the producer of a new documentary on
what is the third
biggest killer of young adults in the uk
and at quarter tonight former world
heavyweight champion boxer david hake
joins us
to tell us about his new face mask
that's raising money
for the nhs
now the criticism over david cameron's
lobbying activities takes
another twist today let's talk to our
correspondent
ali forza skew uh what's going to be
happening so
uh we've got an opposition day debate
that labour forced in the house of
commons what they want
is they want the inquiry that we know
has already been ordered by number 10
tapped
into this green sale scandal they want
that to happen within parliament so they
want a select committee to be set up to
look at the green sill
scandal they will be forcing a vote it
is very unlikely they'll win obviously
because we know
the conservatives have a big majority
but it is clear that they're not going
to be letting up pressure on this
um we've also got pmqs today so i'm sure
the prime minister himself will face
a lot of fire on this from labor i think
what's going to be really interesting
though
is whether this is going to be starting
to cut through with the public because
it's a really complicated scandal you
know about government contracts about
supply chains
i'm yet to be convinced that so far it's
really cut through with the public but i
think as we see that pressure coming day
after day
maybe we will see that happening now
worth reminding people that of course
david cameron has already been cleared
by the lobbying watchdog but now
what we are seeing is a conversation
turning really to a broader
look at the murky world of lobbying
questions about um former ministers
current ministers that drink that matt
hancock had with
david cameron and lex green sill the
text with rishi sunak and as i say very
clear today that labour are not going to
be letting up pressure
okay ali thank you
now there have been more clashes in
minnesota overnight as hundreds took to
the streets to protest about the
shooting of a black man by a police
officer it comes
as the defense staked their case in the
trial of the former police officer
accused of murdering george floyd our
u.s correspondent
sally lockwood reports
dante wright's death has reignited in
anger here
a third night of protest since he was
shot by police
just miles from the trial of former
officer derek
shovin for the death of george floyd
if you do not cease your unlawful
behavior and disperse peaceably
you'll be arrested say his name the two
families standing together
in grief outside court you see the pain
that they have dear god
dante wright's mother was on the phone
with him when he was pulled over
i could hear the police officers and
scruffling with him
she called back and spoke on video to a
passenger
said she was crying and screaming and
she said that they shot him
and she pointed the phone towards the
driver's seat and my son was laying
there
unresponsive that was the last time that
i seen my son
that's the last time i heard from my son
and i have had no explanation since then
george floyd's girlfriend here sobbing
with dante's family
told me by a twist of fate she knew him
too i'm crushed um it's enough that
floyd is gone but for one of my youth to
to be gone as well
i worked with dante for years so he knew
don't yes
yes and he's just a wonderful beautiful
boy
inside court derek shovin's lawyers
began presenting their defense
for the first time the jury heard this
was an appropriate use of force
against george floyd in terms of the
initial uses of force
the officers efforts to get mr floyd
into the car you felt that they were
objectively reasonable
i did did the use of force then continue
after mr floyd was restrained
on the ground i don't consider a prone
control
as a use of force
the defense showed video evidence of
george floyd being arrested in 2019
a paramedic testifying mr floyd had
taken opioids
the prosecution argued it hadn't killed
him then
he didn't stop breathing no his heart
didn't stop
no he didn't go into cardiac arrest no
he didn't go into a coma no
the trial may conclude as soon as next
week
but an all too familiar story is playing
out in tandem here
the resignation of the officer who shot
dante wright
has not quelled the anger her 26 year
career
lasting longer than his short life
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis
well we have continuous coverage of the
trial into the killing of george floyd
streaming online on our app on youtube
and on sky's channel 524
now the white police officer who shot
jacob blake in kenosha wisconsin last
year has
been returned to duty kenosha's police
chief said russian
chesky was back from administrative
leave
after an internal review found him to
have been acting within
policy in january prosecutors cleared mr
chesky of all charges related to the
shooting
which left jacob blake paralyzed and
became a major flashpoint in nationwide
protests for racial justice
following the killing of george floyd
some other headlines for you this
morning and egypt has
impounded a cargo ship that blocked the
suez canal for nearly a week and filed
a 600 million pound compensation claim
against its owner the ever given got
stuck last month and had to be dislodged
by a specialist rescue team about 400
vessels were delayed
with many forced to divert around africa
iran says it will increase its
enrichment of uranium to 60
purity its highest figure ever bringing
it closer to
but still short of the levels needed for
a nuclear weapon
it comes after an attack at iran's
natanz nuclear facility which iran has
blamed on israel france says it's
coordinating a response to iran's latest
move with other world powers adding
that it is a serious development
president biden has announced the u.s
will withdraw all troops from
afghanistan by september the 11th to
coincide
with the 20th anniversary of the al
qaeda attacks on america
the departure has been delayed by four
months the previous planned exit date of
the first of may was set by former
president trump in an agreement with the
taliban
last year young people particularly
those who are black have been hit
hardest by the rise in unemployment
during the pandemic
that's according to the resolution
foundation think tank
which warns that the youngest workers
have borne the brunt of job losses
because they disproportionately work in
the sector's worst hit by the crisis
like hospitality and leisure
a bit of breaking news from tesco for
you this morning their pre-tax
profits fell by almost 20 to 825 million
pounds over the last year now that's
despite them also unveiling
a jump in sales during the pandemic
we'll get more reaction to that
throughout the day
now it could have given the world more
time
the words of an italian scientist
formerly employed by the world health
organization
who's told sky news that he was asked to
change a key report which would have
helped countries
deal with the coronavirus pandemic
prosecutors in italy are urging the who
to assist them in their investigations
into how the country dealt with the
virus
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
reports
the gondolas are moored up the ancient
waterways are quiet now
like the rest of the country venice is
in lockdown
the dark streets are virtually empty but
in this quiet
a controversy is growing about the
world's lack of preparation
for the pandemic at the center of it
is this man and his employer the world
health organization
early last year italy was the epicenter
of the covet outbreak
dr francesco zambon was tasked with
sending a detailed plan to
all nations on how to cope based
on italy's response he did it
it was published then it was withdrawn
by the world health organization
the world never got the plan they could
have had what we didn't have
time we didn't have time to prepare
but this report would have allowed them
to buy time which was the by far
the most important uh good uh
for getting better prepared for the
pandemic
the chaotic scenes of overwhelmed
hospitals in northern italy prompted the
who
to provide real-time analysis to help
governments prepare
the report team discovered that italy's
pandemic plan
hadn't changed since 2006 and noted
it dr zambon and his lawyer say it
wasn't an issue until wh officials
told the zambon team to amend the report
and say the plan
had been updated he refused and has
resigned
i think that the problem here is about
the lack of independence
a lack of transparency of the world
health organization
the mandate of the organization is to
preserve to promote the health of the
citizens of the entire world
and the story that happened in a year
shows that the organization is bound
by personal interests by
government interest and by
financial powers
100 miles or so west of venice is
bergamo
one of the worst hit cities in the
pandemic
prosecutors are investigating the
government's covid planning on behalf
of the families of those who died here
they've asked for the who
to help their investigation but so far
it has refused even saying staff members
have immunity from questioning it's left
the prosecution teams confused and
suspicious
and talking to dr zambon
disappeared
responding to our questions the who said
that the report
was published too early and that it had
inconsistencies
and inaccuracies they did however say
that they are reviewing what assistance
they can give
to the prosecutors here in bergamo
[Music]
dr zambon is now unemployed and has been
forced to put his home and his beloved
piano up for sale
the prosecutors in bergamo say he
remains a big part of their
investigation
preliminary findings are expected next
month
mr ramsay sky news in northern italy
this is skyny's breakfast let's see what
the weather's going to do for you this
morning
joe looking all bright and dapper today
is the weather going to be nice
it's not going to be too bad at all
actually starting to see a bit of
sunshine coming through the window
already and high pressure in control so
only subtle changes over the next few
days let's take a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so the high pressure will keep things
very nice and quiet but we'll see subtle
changes as well
certainly as it starts to shift its way
eastwards towards scandinavia
we'll pick up a bit of an easterly flow
which will bring some showers into parts
of lincolnshire
east anglia and the southeast but that's
for tomorrow
starting off this morning it's cold it's
frosty particularly over northern parts
a little more in the way of cloud
through central and northern england has
kept it frost free there
but we've also got some mist and fog
around as well and that's reducing
visibility to around 100 meters in
places so do watch out
if you are out and about early on but
the mist and the fog go the
frost lifts as well we'll see some good
sunny spells also cloud bubbling up as
we've seen over the past few days
and a few showers around far fewer than
we've seen over the past few days
better scattered as well but probably
most likely over parts of wales
and the southwest temperatures 11 to 13
degrees celsius we might manage a 14 or
15
in parts of the west that will be 59
degrees fahrenheit not spectacular
values but in fairly light winds
it will feel pleasant and then as we go
towards evening the showers
and the cloud all melt away
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you now she was looking for
shellfish
not joe another lady and what she found
was a little bit
bigger archaeologist marie wood
unearthed
this fossil of a dinosaur
footprint on a beach in yorkshire
it's huge that is big it's thought to
belong
to the 164 million year old
megalosaurus i think that was about 20
feet tall and weighed
about 1500 pounds
so now plans are in place to display the
fossil in scarborough's rotunda museum
if it can be safely recovered but
look at the size of that and to think it
is 164
million years old it's just phenomenal
now still to come on sky news breakfast
leaders
in aviation are going to meet mps today
to talk about how to safely reopen
international travel
this is uh several hundred thousand
deadweight tons of steel
being pushed through salt water
what they literally did was ram into
asia their stern kicked out
went aground in africa and they hung
over the suez
it's just an industry that's very much
out of sight
on the high seas and out of mine it
could be
pilot error it could be machinery it
could be external
elements
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around us
[Music]
india's fatality rate is less than two
percent one of the lowest in the world
the concern here is that the public
health care system
is inadequate
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for
prime minister modi's decisively
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now here's a question that i know a lot
of you are asking
let me tell you i'm asking it as well
will we be able to go
on holiday abroad this year
well sort of fingers crossed isn't it
mps are meeting with leaders in the
aviation and travel sector this morning
to talk about the government
recommendations on how to enable the
safe return
of international travel well we can talk
to two people who are going to be
talking to mps this morning brian sutton
general secretary of the british airline
pilots association
one of those who's due to attend
alongside luke pretheridge
from abda which represents travel agents
good to see you both
this morning brian can i start with you
i mean
what are your key concerns going to be
that you're going to be putting forward
this morning
airlines aviation and the whole travel
sector on their
knees have been crippled by the
coronavirus crisis
um passengers were hoping that the
government report was going to tell them
when they could go on holiday abroad
this summer that was the whole point of
it
but the report that came out the other
day was uh the government called it a
road map
but i've never seen a road map with all
the destinations blanked out
we won't know until next month which
countries the government say are on this
so-called green list
um that it's okay to travel to or on a
red list or an amber list
people are going to have to take
expensive tests they may be
queuing it at airports to go on holiday
so
the other day the government secretary
of state said for the first time
people can start thinking about their
summer holidays well
people actually want to know when they
can go and where they can go those are
the answers we need
those are the points i'll be raising
this morning i suppose luke the problem
with that is it is it's it's data
pacific it all depends on what is
happening in these countries at any
given point in time
yeah i mean i agree that uh with brian's
points there uh
in the main i think overall is welcome
that the government has restated the
ambition to
to restart international travel as soon
as possible hopefully by the 17th of may
it is welcome in principle that we're
getting a traffic light system we've all
been calling for
uh in the industry a risk-based approach
to the restart of international travel
but as brian says there it really is a
lack of detail
within the report that came out from the
global travel task force
and the industry i think does feel an
overriding sense of frustration with
that lack of detail we particularly need
to know
the kind of criteria of how countries
are going to be assessed so not
necessarily the countries at this point
as brian said we're going to get that in
early may but to not even know what the
criteria behind that are at this point i
think many in the industry
were disappointed not to get more
information on that and again as brian
alluded to
testing is going to be a major barrier
to travel this summer we need the
government to engage with the industry
and how we can bring down the cost of
testing
and indeed to look at the approach
that's being followed anyway within the
within the global travel task force
report particularly for low-risk
countries we cannot understand why
countries in the green
category should require a pcr test uh we
we believe a double kind of lateral flow
uh test approach would be a more
proportionate
approach to follow in in that category
yes
i mean both raising concerns about the
testing and in terms of
you think it's a cost problem brian for
a lot of people as much as anything else
i've got to be honest because we're all
getting a sort of test for free when we
need one
whether it's pcr or lateral flow at the
moment i mean i'm not aware how much a
pcr
test would actually cost if i wanted to
go on holiday
well there's a whole range of prices
being being quoted i think the average
cost is about 120 pounds per person
last night somebody told me they'd seen
somewhere that offers quite a
quite a cheap test and i looked that up
and i didn't think it was very reputable
company and that's a
danger of course that people go looking
for cheap ways of
of getting tests but i think if the
government's demanding these tests the
government should be subsidizing them
to make the price reasonable and i think
government should kick-start the whole
of
international travel by offering all the
tests
free to our frontline key workers they
they deserve that they deserve a holiday
it would be a really good way to get
this initiative underway yeah you can
certainly see
how that would be problematic for a you
know a family of four what have you
having to pay for
for four of those in terms of of outer's
position
luke in all of this i mean and the play
it applies to both of you
but i guess the problem is with with the
the lack of clarity over how this road
map is gonna
work moving forward means i guess people
just aren't booking
at the moment i mean it's it who wants
to take the risk
yeah well firstly on the testing point
just just quickly i think it is
important to point out it's not just the
cost of course which we do need
government to to intervene and kind of
try and bring that down
but also the report doesn't say anything
about the treatment of vaccinated
individuals and whether or not they will
be exempted from testing requirements
which seems to be
again a proportionate approach it
doesn't talk about whether children will
require a test or not
but looking at bookings of holidays i
mean apple's position there is that
people can
continue to book a holiday if you're
booking a package holiday then you are
guaranteed to to
either receive your holiday a
alternative
if you're unable to go to the
destination perhaps that you have picked
but still want to travel which we know
many people will want to do
after a year perhaps not getting away
and if none of that can happen then you
will of course receive a refund there is
the package travel regulations you are
you are uh protected financially when
you book a package holiday so
we would hope that people are feeling
confident enough to still go out there
and book at this time
brian just how much is the aviation
industry on its knees
at this time i mean for a lot of us we
we hear about it but because we're not
we're not getting on a plane so we don't
think about it too much so people like
you actually in the business
how difficult has it been and how how
problematic is it going to be
to try and get the industry back up and
running
well flying is 85
down on pre pandemic levels passenger
numbers are 95
down we've seen the collapse of two
airlines
flybe and norwegian air uk we've seen
thousands and thousands of
job losses i can look out my office
window here to my right and see a quiet
heathrow
with a flight every 30 minutes whereas
it used to be every 30 seconds
it's very hard to describe the the depth
of the
recession the crisis that aviation and
the whole travel sector is in
and that's why we've been shouting and
screaming really
for government to give us a way out of
this and if they're not going to if
they're going to say it's too dangerous
too risky
fine in that case step in and help this
industry
which is vital to the whole uk economy i
i just wonder luke
as you prepare to to face uh this
committee today
do you think they're going to listen to
you do you think you're giving evidence
is going to make any difference
well i certainly hope so i mean as brian
was saying you know it's been a very
tough year for everyone in the travel
industry travel agents tour operators
travel management companies have to
represent
revenue down by around 90 percent
across the year uh we know that you know
around 80 000 people more than 80 000
people in the outbound travel sector
have lost
their jobs the industry does need a road
map to recovery and we do need
uh mps to listen to what is being said
today and as brian said you know if we
don't get
uh that road map to recovery and what
the report does make clear is we are
facing many months of constraints on the
travel industry then what is also needed
is
is
tailored financial support for for those
operating in the international travel
sector in the way that other
sectors of the uk economy have been
supported and that's another point that
we will be making today that we hope
mps and indeed the government will act
upon okay luke
and brian thank you and good luck with
your evidence today
now it's claimed the uk's woods and
trees are
approaching a crisis point because of
climate change
so we sent our reporter milena
veselinovich to a forest
to find out what's happening britain's
woods are places filled with magic
but this fragile habitat is under threat
land development climate change and
pollution are encroaching on it
and scientists say consequences could be
dire
we could start to see species
extinctions from some of our woods
but also just the experience that people
have in woodlands is going to be much
less rich
so you're going to go into woodlands and
unlike this woodland which is a prime
example
you're not going to be able to see all
the spring flowers anymore you won't be
able to hear the birds anymore
a new report by the woodland trust says
only 7
of native woods in the uk are in a good
condition
and nearly all exceed thresholds for
nitrogen pollution
a by-product of farming climate change
is also shifting the timing of seasonal
events
caterpillars are for example emerging
earlier
and blue tits and other birds that rely
on those aren't able to feed on them
because they
they're hatching and so on is affected
by day lengths not by temperature
so we are seeing sort of losses of
wildlife in that way
but keeping the woods healthy is key to
the future of the planet
this ancient wood is more than 400 years
old and
trees here capture carbon and store it
for centuries
they could be one of our greatest allies
in the fight against climate change
trees and plants are second only to the
ocean at generating oxygen
they actively sequester the carbon
dioxide from our atmosphere
and gather it and store it within their
bodies
this is really really important towards
the fight against greenhouse gas
emissions increasing within our
atmosphere
experts say we need to quadruple the
amount of trees we are planting
to give nature a chance of recovery if
we don't they say
there's much to lose vaselinovich
sky news just a reminder you can keep up
with stories like this every day on the
daily climate show
it's on sky news every weekday a half
past six and a half past nine
with anna jones still to come on sky
news breakfast
we're going to be talking to the former
olympic hectic denise lewis about how
the ongoing pandemic
is going to affect this year's games
which starts
in 100 days
from my experience swimming was never
priority when i was growing up
my mother couldn't swim and my father
couldn't swim either so
it was never a priority so we never did
it and as i grew older it became
something that
it never even featured in my lifestyle
so
if anybody ever asked me if i could swim
i just you know
said of course no i can't remember
because at that time i started hearing
about the stereotypes
and the stigmas and the myths and it was
it's easier to just hide behind them
so um i just didn't the statistics
says that um also the curriculum
which is across all schools in the in
the uk states that um
by the time a child finishes primary
school they should be able to stream 25
meters perform two kinds of two
different kind of strokes
and also get themselves out of a water
safety in your situation or
what's a safety test um i think the
national average is around about 70
percent of children are able to achieve
this by time they finish primary school
but when you go to the black and ethnic
minority areas it goes down to
42 percent so although
um swimming um is in the curriculum
in schools it seems that in the black
and ethnic minority areas
it just doesn't it just doesn't happen
the way it's supposed to and i put that
down to it's not being a priority i
wrote as
um a letter um to the word to a letter
to the world in the form of a song
and which appears on the black count
swim sound official soundtrack
and basically i said that it's the
younger generation
it's the youth it's the youth that are
going to be able to change the narrative
and so i'm looking at the between the 14
and the 25 year olds
that age group that can change the
narrative and hence the reason why
um i created the sequel
to last counseling based on that
demographics
they can't swim while they don't want to
go to the pool they can swim
but they just don't want to
you know when you're black and and
you're in a situation with
with mostly white people you already
know all the ways that you're different
maybe we need like the equivalent of the
usain bolt or the track
on in the pool you know i mean we need
one guy just to pop up out of nowhere
and just start slapping gold medals
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
[Applause]
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we all
work together we can really make a
difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah
we should really do that
it's a mostly dry start to the day with
quite a widespread frost over northern
parts
further south there's some mist and fog
which will give way to sunny spells
later
and for many it's going to be a very
pleasant day we will see a few showers
cropping up
particularly over parts of wales and the
southwest temperatures into double
figures we could see a 13 or a 14
somewhere that's 57 degrees fahrenheit
and the air pollution levels which have
been low for quite a few days so now
will remain low there is a chance of
them rising to moderate come the weekend
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now today marks a hundred days until the
start of tokyo
2020. i presume they're still calling in
tokyo 2020
but questions remain over athlete
vaccination possible lockdown measures
and
whether anyone outside of japan is going
to be able to attend well as team gb
athletes prepare for the games
olympian denise lewis is fronting a
campaign to pay tribute to those
who've supported others with mental
health this year and she joins us now
it's good to see you this morning look
at all those trophies behind you
wow that's quite a deal
that's quite a display uh look how in
terms of
in terms of team gb how much
anticipation do you think there's going
to be a hundred days out
on the basis that we think it is going
to happen
i i think this is a significant uh
moment you know
just over three months to go to the
start of the games
and for athletes delegations everyone
involved who have had to go through
the cancellation of the games this is a
landmark top moment
and athletes will still be preparing
although we're surrounded by this
air of i guess uncertainty
to put it mildly i think it's business
as usual for the athletes they have been
preparing
for the games they got cancelled last
year they will still
want to be at those games listen it's a
competition that is
is viewed by billions it will still be
the most viewed
championships uh this summer and there's
still medals to be won so athletes will
have that in their
their minds i mean you understand the
pressures of this
more than the rest of us will ever know
do you think it has been an advantage to
have an extra year to prepare
or a disadvantage that you know they
were things were just cancelled last
year
i think it will really depend on who you
ask you know there are athletes that
have
elongated their their competition and
their training year
in order to compete at the the olympics
there will be athletes that have been
injured
and probably welcome that extra time but
i think
it's very it's varied but it's the
uncertainty that
i think still hangs around for a lot of
people
with it go on um i guess athletes have
shown great resilience
in in keeping going keeping their
training
and that is the case for the rest of the
nation that uh
british public have shown great
resilience
getting through this pandemic and
as we um sort of look at the road map um
for the rest of the the
the year in the summer it's it's those
kind of things that give you
hope and the athletes are in the same
situation
there are reports the japanese
government is thinking of banning
overseas
spectators we don't know if that's
actually going to happen or not
will that matter um for the for the
athletes in the sense that
they still expect the stadia to be full
i guess with with locals
and i guess you're sort of surrounded by
your teams and
the british camp anyway will it make a
huge difference
i think everyone's adjusted to a new
norm we've seen
sports take place uh without crowds
um already for months um and so there is
a a training of the mind to
to be prepared that it might not be his
fault um
it might be half full some of the
stadiums but athletes are
are determined to compete you know they
relish the opportunity for competition
and if it's uh just locals then so be it
i think it's just important that
the olympics are such a um an iconic
sporting occasion for so many reasons
that it's important to go ahead
you talked earlier about how you know
everyone's coped during lockdown
it's been it's been very hard and
particularly hard i think a lot of
people would agree
for parents i know you've got four
youngsters i mean
it must be it must have been really hard
work
sort of parenting and schooling and
everything else 24 hours a day
and how how do we need to then build
people up from from that level of stress
and
and the the sort of the the mental
problems that can because
because it's bound to have an effect on
mental health even if only slightly
um yes i i think the key for
everyone and what was what's what's been
shown through the pandemic is that
people have relied on activities very
simple activities
such as walking um cycling
um and baking you know there's been a
lot of faking i know we did that in the
household um
my husband is now an expert at making
sourdough
um but i think it is that finding those
exercises
that help you and haven who are one of
the
team gb partners have done conducted
some research
and the research has shown that 16 to 24
year olds
have suffered over half of them really
were impacted by the their mental
wellness was impacted by
the pandemic and during the pandemic um
and they're running a competition
which i think is really wonderful for
the british public to
nominate some of those lock-down heroes
that
helped other individuals get through
find a coping strategy
and um i think it's a lovely competition
so if people go onto
haven.com website forward slash team gb
they can nominate their special person
to win a competition and and prizes that
uh
just to say thank you which will be
lovely it is always nice to say thank
you i think um
look uh sky studios in westminster
if uh if your husband would like to send
some sourdough bread down i'm just
saying
that'd be very nice good to talk to you
this morning thank you
thank you okay let's get a quick check
on the weather with joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well the
coming days look very much like
each other with just subtle differences
today some mist and fog around to start
off with way too sunny spells
cloud bubbling up through the day one or
two showers but very isolated
if anything most likely over parts of
wales in the southwest and temperatures
into double figures for most
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you coming up we'll be having
a look at a major uk
trial to see if we can mix and match
vaccines
[Music]
[Music]
so
you